So, okay. Herr Schlüter, was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Also mir geht es seit einiger Zeit schon nicht so gut.
Ich habe immer solche Bauchschmerzen und es wird eigentlich gar nicht besser.
Und ich fühle mich jetzt auch wirklich so ein bisschen schlapp.
Und was mir jetzt aufgefallen ist, ja und meine Kollegen haben mich darauf eigentlich aufmerksam gemacht,
dass ich so zitterig bin, dass ich manchmal so die Hände, dass die so zittern,
dass ich gar nicht richtig so die Hände ruhig halten kann.
Und ja, also irgendwie bin ich schlecht drauf zur Zeit.
Okay, also Sie haben Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, die Bauchschmerzen, die werden tatsächlich immer schlimmer.
Seit wann haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Das geht schon, das geht schon echt fast ein Vierteljahr, würde ich sagen.
Ein Vierteljahr.
Ja, und dann habe ich immer gedacht, naja, geht schon wieder weg.
Und dann habe ich mal einen Schnaps getrunken, damit es besser wird.
Und ja, zum Einschlafen trinke ich dann auch noch einen Schnaps.
Aber nein, irgendwie, es drückt wirklich tüchtig im Bauch.
Also die Schmerzen sind schon drückend. Und wie noch würden Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ja, tatsächlich, also dass das drückt, ne?
Ja, und schlecht ist mir natürlich auch so ein bisschen, ne?
Ja.
Wo genau bestehen die Bauchschmerzen? Also linke Seite, rechte Seite?
Na, ich würde schon sagen in der Mitte, so oberhalb vom Bauchnabel.
Oben im Bauch.
Okay, streuen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, das ist nur hier im Bauch, aber das schlecht geht es mir halt.
Das ist es so, ne?
Also, ja, dass mir so schlecht ist und dass ich die Treppen nicht mehr gut hochkomme.
Mit einmal habe ich so das Problem, dass ich nie mehr so gut Luft kriege.
Ja, wie gesagt, dann dieses, ja, das merke ich schon auch selber, dass ich so ein bisschen unruhig bin.
Und, ja, also, ich meine, ja, mir geht es einfach schlecht zurzeit.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe. Also Sie leiden unter Atemnot?
Ja, wenn ich mich anstrengen muss, wenn ich also die Treppe schnell hochgehe oder so,
dann muss ich schon ein bisschen husten, ja, zumal wenn ich irgendwie einen Kasten Bier trage oder so, ne?
Okay, also Sie können nicht Treppe steigen?
Ja, dann habe ich Probleme mit der Luft, genau.
Okay, und wenn Sie sich ausruhen, ist es wieder besser?
Dann ist gut, ja, ja, dann geht es wieder, ja.
Okay, Sie haben auch gesagt, dass Sie husten, hadern. Ist es mit Auswurf oder trockene Husten?
Nee, das ist eigentlich nur so ein bisschen so trocken, da kommt extra aus, nee.
Und husten ist mit Atemnot verbindet?
Nee, Atemnot ist das eigentlich nur, wenn ich die Treppe hoch, also wenn ich mich doll anstrengen muss,
wenn ich, was weiß ich, jemandem hinterherlaufen muss oder wenn ich eine Treppe hoch muss oder wenn ich etwas Schweres trage, ne?
Ja, ich verstehe. Verspüren Sie auch Herzrasen oder Herzstolpern?
Ja, manchmal denke ich schon, dass es ein bisschen schneller klopft als normal, ja.
Ist es störend oder?
Ja, also manchmal ist es schon so, dass es mich so ein bisschen, ja, dass es mich ein bisschen stört, ja.
Also sind die Herzrasen oder Herzstolpern auch mit Belastung, körperliche Belastung verbindet?
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist das so, wahrscheinlich ist das so, ja, ja, ja.
Und wieder zu Bauchschmerzen, gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für die Bauchschmerzen?
Das kann ich gar nicht sagen, also ich wüsste nicht, warum das angefangen hat, ja.
Also mit einmal war es halt da und wird überhaupt nicht besser.
Ok. Haben Sie schon Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Übelkeit oder Erbrechen gelitten?
Ziemlich heul, also mir ist ziemlich oft schlecht, ja.
Und ja, und dann schmeckt mir auch das Essen nicht, aber was ganz komisch ist,
obwohl ich tatsächlich ganz, also nicht viel esse, weil ich gar nicht so richtig Appetit habe,
trotzdem habe ich zugenommen in letzter Zeit.
Wie viel Kilogramm?
Ich glaube, dass, ja, das sind bestimmt so, ich wiege mich ja nicht ständig,
aber was ich vor allen Dingen merke, dass meine Hosen kneifen, ja,
und dass die mir nicht mehr passen, ne?
Ok, wir können sagen schon, also können wir ungefähr 5 Kilogramm sagen oder?
Ja, vielleicht 3 Kilogramm.
Ja, vielleicht so 3, 3 Kilo sind das bestimmt mehr, ja.
Bestimmt mehr, also in welchem Zeitraum haben Sie zugenommen?
Also kann man sagen in den letzten 3 Monaten oder?
Ja, so ungefähr haut das hin, ja.
Wie stark sind die Bauchschmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10?
Wobei 0 schmerzfrei und 10 die Stärke Schmerzen beschreiben?
Also ich kann das ja aushalten, ich laufe damit ja jetzt schon eine ganze Weile rum,
also vielleicht so in der Mitte würde ich sagen, so zwischen 0 und 10, also die Hälfte, ne?
Ok, dann sagen wir erst 5. Ok, die sind störend, aber sie können trotzdem aushalten.
Ja, genau, so kann man das sagen.
Aber was halt wirklich ist, dass ich mit einmal so unruhig bin,
dass ich so, ja, so ein bisschen zitterig, ne?
Ja, zittern Sie eh den ganzen Zeit oder manchmal?
Ja, den ganzen Tag nicht, aber manchmal merke ich das,
also wenn ich mir, zum Beispiel ja morgens beim Zähneputzen,
wenn ich mir Zahnpasta auf die Zahnbürste tun will, dass das ein bisschen schwierig ist,
oder beim Einschenken vom Glas, dass ich dann merke, die Hände gehorchen nicht so richtig, ne?
Dann trinke ich das Bier schon mal aus der Flasche statt aus dem Glas, ja.
Ja, ok, es ist leichter.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Ne, mit dem Wasserlassen?
Das geht, also Stuhlgang, ja, da habe ich in letzter Zeit, also ja, da habe ich ziemlich oft Durchfall, ne?
Da muss ich oft mehrmals am Tag, da muss ich auf die Toilette und dann ist das ganz schnell.
Und was ganz lästig ist, ja, dass ich auch so, ja, so Blehungen habe,
dass ich immer wieder so Luft im Bauch habe und ja, wenn man dann nicht aufpasst,
dann kommt halt Durchfall mit, also ich muss schon immer oft auf die Toilette gehen.
Ja, gibt es bestimmte Lebensmittel, die die Blehungen und deren Durchfall auslösen?
Es ist mir noch nicht aufgefallen, ich wüsste jetzt nicht, eigentlich habe ich immer alles vertragen.
Also ich wüsste nicht, dass ich irgendwas nicht vertragen kann.
Ok, ich verstehe. Haben Sie vielleicht Blut im Stuhl gesehen?
Ich habe es mir nicht angeguckt, aber das wäre mir doch wahrscheinlich aufgefallen.
Ja, ne, also auch beim Abputzen oder so, da ist nie Blut.
Ok, ja, Sie haben Blut nicht bemerkt. Hauptsache ist das.
Und Sie haben kein Problem mit Wasserlassen?
Nö, da habe ich eigentlich kein Problem.
Ok, können Sie gut schlafen?
Ja, zurzeit schlafe ich nicht so gut, weil ich oft nachts so schwitze, wache ich auf und bin klatschnass geschwitzt, ja,
obwohl es ja gar nicht so heiß ist oder so, in meinem Zimmer ist es jetzt auch nicht so warm, ja, aber ja, also da schlafe ich zurzeit eher nicht so gut, ja.
Wegen nachtschweiße?
Ja, also ja, ich schwitze da halt in der Nacht, ne.
Ok, fühlen Sie sich auch tagsüber fiebrig?
Ne, eigentlich Fieber habe ich, denke ich nicht. Ich habe aber auch nicht gemessen, ich glaube ich habe gar keinen Fiebertermometer zu Hause.
Ok, aber Sie haben sich auch nicht fiebrig gefühlt?
Ne, ne, aber wie gesagt, nur unruhig, aber nachts schwitze ich wirklich doll, ja.
Ja, ich verstehe, Fieberstürfrost hatten Sie nicht.
Herr Schlüter, ist bei Ihnen schon chronische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ne, also eigentlich war ich immer gesund, ich meine ich bin ja auch noch nicht so alt, ne.
Ja, natürlich, Sie sind schon sehr jung.
Ja, aber also ja, ich war mal beim Hausarzt und der hat dann was gesagt, mit der Leber wäre irgendwas, deswegen gehe ich da auch nicht so gerne hin, ja.
Was hat er über Leber gesagt?
Er hat gesagt, ich soll nicht so viel trinken, aber ja, das ist leichter gesagt als getan, ja.
Ok, Sie haben schon eine bekannte Leberkrankheit, aber wissen Sie nicht, was es ist?
Ja, er hat nur gesagt, dass die, wenn man Blut abnimmt, dass dann die Werte schlecht sind, ne.
Aha, und Sie müssen aufhören mit Alkoholkonsum oder?
Ja, das sagt er mir immer, aber das will ich halt nicht, ne.
Wie soll ich denn das Leben aushalten ohne Alkohol?
Ja, haben Sie recht.
Ja, das ist mir aber wirklich nicht.
Wie viel Alkohol trinken Sie pro Tag?
Ja, also ja, wie gesagt, mal einen Schnaps und ein paar Flaschen Bier, dann am Abend zum Runterkommen und ja, was ich beim Fernsehen oder wenn ich mich mit Kumpels treffe zum Kartenspielen, dann trinken wir schon ein paar Flaschen Bier, ja.
Also täglich ein paar Flaschen Bier?
Ja, ja, ja.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ja, also nicht mehr so viel, also ein Päckchen am Tag ist es schon noch, früher habe ich mal eine Zeitlang fast zwei Päckchen am Tag geraucht, ja, aber ja, jetzt so ein Päckchen am Tag rauche ich noch.
Seit wie vielen Jahren?
Ja, ich habe das jetzt ein bisschen reduziert, vielleicht schon so seit drei Jahren oder so, aber vorher, eigentlich seit ich erwachsen bin, habe ich immer stark geraucht.
Also kann man sagen seit 20 Jahren?
Bestimmt, ja.
Ok, Herr Schlüter, ich habe noch eine Frage, aber bitte nehmen Sie es nicht persönlich an, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Oh, das ist schon lange her, da habe ich mal so ein bisschen so haschig geraucht, ja, so Marihuana, das war mal so bei den jungen...
Was haben Sie geraucht?
Marihuana.
Marihuana war mal so bei uns jungen Leuten damals, war das groß im Trend und da habe ich das natürlich auch probiert und ja, auch ganz schön...
Aber jetzt normalerweise haben Sie, rauchen Sie nicht Marihuana?
Jetzt nicht mehr, nein, das war in meiner wilden Zeit, als ich jung war, ja.
Ok, ok.
Aber jetzt nicht mehr, nein.
Ok, das wüsste ich, das möchte ich wissen, das wollte ich wissen.
Also die erhöhte Lebewerte ist bei Ihnen noch nicht andere, ist bei Ihnen nicht andere chronische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Nein, nein, sonst, das einzige, was ich noch mal hatte, da hatte ich mir den Unterschenkel gebrochen und das musste operiert werden, aber sonst war ich nie krank.
Unterschenkel haben Sie gebrochen, welche Seite?
Ja, da hatte ich einen Unfall, bitte?
Welche Seite?
Ja, auf der linken Seite.
Also vor wie vielen Jahren sind Sie operiert worden?
Das muss schon so 15 Jahre her sein.
Ist bei Ihnen noch andere Operationen durchgeführt worden?
Nee.
Also diese Unterschenkeloperation?
Also noch nicht bei dem Blindarm raus oder so, sonst war nie was.
Super, Sie sind ja fast kerngesund.
Bis auf meine Bauchschmerzen, ja.
Ja, bis jetzt. Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf ein?
Ja, also wenn ich mal einen dicken Kopf hab, also Kopfschmerzen hab, dann nehm ich mal Aspirin oder so, ja.
Also Sie nehmen Aspirin bei Bedarf?
Ja, wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen hab, ja.
Okay, sonst nix.
Nee, sonst nehm ich eigentlich nix.
Ja, super, toll. Ist bei Ihnen Allergin bekannt, Herr Schlüter?
Nee, weil ich dachte, ich kann eigentlich alles vertragen, also bisher auch nicht, dass ich irgendwie so Heuschnupfen oder so was hab, was andere Leute haben. Nee, nee, sowas hab ich alles nicht.
Okay, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Boah, wenn ich das mal so genau wüsste. Ich hab mich dann zweimal, glaub ich, damals, als das mit Corona war, da bin ich mal geimpft worden, aber jetzt schon lange nicht mehr.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Im Ausland? Nee, da hab ich gar kein Geld dafür.
Achso, okay. Ist in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja, meine Mutter, das weiß ich, also die ist ja jetzt auch nicht mehr jung und die hat so, also einmal weiß ich, dass die irgendwie ein bisschen hohen Bluthochdruck hat.
Einen hohen Blutdruck hat und dann hat die so diesen Alterszucker, die muss immer jetzt irgendwie so Tabletten nehmen, das hat der Arzt mal festgestellt.
Ach ja. Und Ihre Vater?
Mein Vater lebt schon nicht mehr. Der hat irgendwas gehabt an der Leber früher, das weiß ich wohl.
Also ist er an Lebererkrankungen gestorben?
Ich glaube, dass er daran auch gestorben ist, ja, ich denke wohl. Und der war auch so ein bisschen durcheinander zum Schluss.
Achso, es tut mir leid zu hören. Das soll ja schwer sein.
Es soll ja schwer sein. Haben Sie Geschwister, Herr Schlüter?
Nee, ich war alleine als Kind, ich hab keine Geschwister gehabt.
Wie ist Ihre Familienstand?
Ich bin geschieden.
Ja, es tut mir leid zu hören, es soll ja schwierig sein und stressig sein.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, aber die sind bei meiner Frau zum Glück, ja.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, so viel ich weiß. Ich höre und sehe die nicht so oft, aber ich meine, die sind fit, ja.
Aber falls Sie eine Krankheit hätten, würden Sie es natürlich wissen?
Ja, das wüsste ich schon, ja. Also die haben natürlich mal Schnupfen und Husten und was weiß ich, aber die sind einig, sind die gesund, ja.
Was machen Sie als beruflich, Herr Schlüter?
Ja, also ich bin in so einem Baumarkt, arbeite ich.
Baumarkt.
Fülle da auf und helfe bei der Kundenberatung mit so ein bisschen und vor allen Dingen Sachen hin und her tragen und so.
Und dann merke ich halt, dass mir das zurzeit schwerfällt, wenn ich schwer arbeiten muss, wenn ich schwer heben muss.
Ja, und Sie leiden ja unter Atemnot bei körperlicher Belastung. Deswegen kann ich mir vorstellen, wie stressig es ist.
Noch ein paar Fragen, Herr Schlüter. Fühlen Sie unter, verspüren Sie Völlegefühl?
Also Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Ihre Appetit sich reduziert hat. Fühlen Sie Völlegefühl? Also essen Sie weniger als sonst?
Also bestimmt esse ich weniger als sonst, aber umso mehr ärgert mich, dass meine Hosen alle so eng werden, ja.
Ich musste jetzt kürzlich bei der Eilmuster schon den Knopf offen lassen, sonst hätte ich die gar nicht anziehen können.
Ja, ich verstehe, ich verstehe.
Und zu Hause ziehe ich dann am liebsten nur noch so Jogginghosen an, weil dann drückt das nicht am Bauch.
Ist Ihnen vielleicht Hautveränderungen aufgefallen?
Hautveränderungen? Ich wüsste nicht. Also keine Ahnung. Ich glaube nicht, dass da irgendwas Besonderes ist.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie zugenommen haben. Ist Ihre Bauchumfang sich vergrößert?
Ja, die Hosen passen nicht mehr. Ich kriege die Hosen oben nicht mehr zu.
Davon denke ich schon, dass der Bauch mehr geworden ist, ja.
Haben Sie an Ihren Beinen, besonders im Unterschenkel, Schwellungen bemerkt?
Manchmal sieht man so ein bisschen von den Socken den Rand, dass das ein bisschen einschnürt, aber nicht schlimm.
Also hat es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Ihre Schuhe nicht mehr anpassen oder verengst sind?
Die Schuhe passen noch nie, nur die Socken drücken manchmal ein bisschen.
Okay, also Sie haben schon Beinschwellungen, kann man sagen.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen, Herr Schlüter?
Jetzt habe ich Ihnen doch so viel erzählt. Jetzt will ich nur ganz gerne wissen, woran liegt denn das.
Ich will natürlich auch wissen, ob das vielleicht Krebs ist oder so.
Ich habe natürlich ein bisschen Sorge jetzt, weil es mir nicht so gut geht.
Ja, ich kann Sie verstehen. Also wir werden gleich die körperlichen Untersuchungen durchführen.
Wir werden auch nochmal Ihre Lebewerte kontrollieren.
Es ist schon festgestellt, erhöhte Lebewerte bei Ihnen.
Und wir sehen mal, was wir machen können für Sie.
Okay.
Dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder.
Möchte ich jemand von Ihnen noch eine zusätzliche Frage stellen?
Ich denke mal, das war eine sehr ausführliche, sehr präzise Anamnese.
Haben Sie sich schön geschlagen.
Möchte jemand irgendetwas noch zusätzlich?
Ich wüsste eigentlich jetzt nicht, was offen geblieben ist, aber vielleicht hat noch jemand eine Frage.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe akustisch nicht gehört. Vielleicht haben Sie ...
... strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwohin aus?
Hat sie gefragt, habe ich aber verneint.
Okay. Und noch eins bitte.
Wie stark sind Sie mit der Lebewerte?
Ich habe sie nicht gehört.
Okay.
Und noch eins bitte.
Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala?
Wobei nur kein Schmerz zählt, am stärksten Schmerz entspricht.
Ja, das hat sie auch gefragt.
Und ich habe dann selber gesagt, so in der Mitte, und daraufhin hat meine Ärztin gesagt,
ja, dann nehme ich fünf als mittleren Wert.
Und das hat sie auch so eingetragen.
Ja, Entschuldigung, gibt es da Probleme?
Nee, ist gut.
Deswegen möchte ich fragen noch mal, und wie sah Ihren Stuhl aus?
Das hat sie nicht gefragt. Wie der Stuhl aussah, hat sie nicht gefragt.
Das habe ich gefragt und ich habe Blut auch zurückgegeben.
Blut haben Sie gefragt.
Ich habe gefragt, wie sah es aus und haben Sie vielleicht Blut bemerkt?
Genau.
Er hat nicht geantwortet, wie es aussah.
Er hat nur gesagt, Blut war da nicht, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Und wie Durchfall so aussieht, flüssiger Stuhlgang.
Ja, und Sie haben das vielleicht gemerkt.
Ich glaube, die Kollegin, die jetzt gerade eben auch gefragt hat, war, dass sie neulich gesagt hat,
ja, wie ist das denn, wenn jemand so umgangssprachlich spricht?
Da war ich jetzt bei Ihnen natürlich an einer guten Adresse, weil Sie das alles sehr gut verstehen konnten.
Weil Sie diese umgangssprachlichen Formulierungen unterzubringen wussten.
Da könnte es jetzt sein, dass da vielleicht auch ein bisschen Unsicherheit bei den Zuhörern gekommen ist,
dass Sie vielleicht nicht alles verstanden haben.
Dieser Patient hat ja jetzt nicht akademisch gesprochen, sage ich mal.
Genau. Mir ist schlecht.
Ja.
Ja, gerne.
Seit wann sind Sie geschieden und mitnehmen Sie Leben?
Ach, seit wann ich geschieden bin.
Ach, schon acht Jahre und ich lebe alleine.
Ja, ich stelle auf die Zeit ein.
Hallo, guten Tag Frau Dr. Oberärztin.
Ich habe einen neuen Patent aufgenommen und ich würde Ihnen gerne vorstellen, falls Sie Zeit haben.
Ja, natürlich. Wen haben Sie gesehen?
Also der 48-jährige Marc Schlüter ist ein Patient, der seit 20 Jahren in der Medizin ist.
Also der 48-jährige Marc Schlüter ist 1,80 Meter groß und wiegt 86 Kilogramm.
Herr Schlüter hat sich heute vor drei Monate aufgetretene, drückende, prokidierte Oberwachschmerzen ohne Ausstrahlung vor.
Die Bauchschmerzen liegen bei 5 auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10.
Es gibt keine Auslöser für die Bauchschmerzen.
Außerdem hat er berichtet, dass er unter Nozère, Meteorismus, Füllgefühl, Diarrhea leidet.
Außer dieser gastrointestinalen Beschwerden leidet er auch unter belastungabhängige Dyspnoe und trockene Tussis und Tachycardie und Palpitations.
Außerdem hat er erwähnt, dass er Nervosität und Hände zittern habe.
Er hat berichtet, dass seine Appetit sich vermindert habe.
Trotz seiner verminderten Appetit hat er in den letzten drei Monaten 3 Kilogramm zugenommen und besonders sein Bauchumfeld hat sich vergrößert.
Er leidet auch an Insomnie wegen Nachtschweiß.
Er hat auch berichtet, dass er Beinschwellungen hat.
Er leidet nicht an festgestellten chronischen Erkrankungen.
Seine Hausarztin hat bei ihm erhöhte Leberwerte festgestellt und eine Diät hat er empfohlen, besonders Alkoholkarenz.
Aber Herr Schlüter hat gesagt, dass er sich nicht daran halte.
Er sei vor 15 Jahren wegen linker Unterschenkelfraktur operiert worden.
Er nimmt nur Aspirin bei Bedarf ein.
Er sei vollständig geimpft und die Reise an Amnese ist unauffällig.
Herr Schlüter rauche seit 3 Jahren 20 Zigaretten pro Tag.
20 Zigaretten ist die verminderte Zahl.
Er trinkt ein paar Flaschen Bier täglich.
Er nimmt keine Drogen.
Das reicht ja auch, was er sonst an Drogen hat.
Der Vater von Herr Schlüter war an einer Lebererkrankung gestorben.
Seine Mutter leidet an Arthelie-Hypertonie und Diabetes mellitus.
Er lebt alleine und hat Kinder, die gesund sind.
Er arbeitet als Baumarktarbeiter.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Vermutung?
Die Differenzialdiagnostik kann auch eine Reisdarm-Syndrom sein.
Es kann eine kohlig entzündliche Darm-Krankung sein.
Es kann Hypertereuse sein.
Es kann vielleicht Kalzinoid sein.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch, um Ihre Diagnose zu bestätigen?
Ich werde den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Worauf achten Sie besonders?
Ich werde den Bauch- und Durchabtasten untersuchen.
Was erwarten Sie denn da?
Ich werde eine schrumpfbegrenzte Leber unter den Bauch.
Was könnte es noch sein?
Ich werde eine digitale Rekteile untersuchen.
Der Patient schildert ja auch neurologische Symptome.
Ich werde auch die Beinschwellungen untersuchen.
Und eine neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Was fällt Ihnen als erstes ein?
Die Muskelschwäche, die Parasthesie-Lähmungen.
Die Motorik und Sensibilität in den Extremitäten.
Was machen Sie noch mit dem Patienten?
Ich werde ein Blut abnehmen.
Was lassen Sie im Labor untersuchen?
Entzündliche Parameter, Blutbild, Leberwerte.
Ich werde auch die Dachcelotonin untersuchen.
Das fällt mir jetzt ein.
Was erwarten Sie als erstes?
Als Bildgeber der Verfahren.
Die Aszitis.
Was würden Sie für eine Therapie vorschlagen?
Ich würde Ihnen natürlich eine Lebensstiländerung empfehlen.
Ich werde Ihnen symptomatisch Therapie durchführen.
Ich werde eine Diuretika für die Aszitis und Beinschwellungen verschreiben.
Und eine symptomatische Therapie.
Was kommt bei Ihren Untersuchungen raus?
Schicken wir den Patienten wieder nach Hause?
Es hat etwas geblieben.
Wir können den Patienten um die Therapie.
Man muss ihn stationär aufnehmen.
Wir haben wenig Handhabe, was seinen Lebensstil angeht, wenn er ambulant ist.
Eine Piskotherapie würde dem Patienten helfen.
Er hat Stress und trinkt Alkohol.
Eine Piskotherapie würde Ihnen helfen.
Das war eine perfekte Ananese.
Ich möchte Ihnen noch eine Ananese-Vorgabe geben.
Ich finde es wieder auf, dass Sie im Ananese-Gespräch
die Ananese in die Ananese verbreitet haben.
Ich würde sagen, dass es besser geworden ist.
Ich verstehe genau, was Sie meinen.
Wenn Sie frei formulieren, sind Sie nicht ganz so souverän.
Ich habe eine Stimme gehalten.
Eine Mikrofon ist eingeführt.
Die freie Formulierung ist schwieriger.
Wenn Sie sagen, der Patient hat gesagt, dass das und das ist,
dürfen Sie nicht den Konjunktiv nehmen.
Ich finde es bewundernswert, wie durchgängig Sie das verwenden.
Ich habe Sie korrigiert.
Ich finde es sehr komisch, dass der Patient das nicht so einfach ist.
Das ist eine winzige grammatikalische Feinheit.
Vielen Dank.
Jetzt sind wir alle komplett.
Ist es in Ihrem Sinne, dass wir uns am Donnerstag treffen?
Ich hatte nur am Anfang, da waren Sie noch nicht dabei,
wegen Ende des Fastenbrechens und Beginn des Ramadan,
aber wenn Sie mir noch eine Stunde wieder gönnen, bin ich froh,
zumal ich in der Woche drauf nicht da bin.
Ich bin nicht zu Hause und würde da keine Anamnese machen.
In der Woche vor Ostern könnte ich Dienstag und Donnerstag noch machen.
Also sehen wir uns am Donnerstag.
Erstmal sage ich Ihnen allen herzlichen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Es macht immer wieder Spaß mit Ihnen. Tschüss zusammen.